Good morning, John. It's Tuesday March 20th
and I have begun watching The Office.
I like The Office. I am on Team Pam.
I haven't met Karen yet. Definitely. So far I'm
a fan of Pam. In fact, maybe too much of a
fan as I've been watching it with
Catherine and repeatedly telling her how
a fan I am of Pam. But it's okay, right?
I mean I can think of four guys right off
the top of my head that Catherine has
crushes on that she's never met.
Eddie Izzard, Christian Bale, Edward Martin,
Hugh Jackman, Hugh Grant. Wait, was that five?
Your little building excursion got me
thinking. It was also my experience with
a punk rock p-beating. Now a lot of
people say that as you get older, you get
smarter, you mature, you start doing less
stupid things and those same people say
that young people are stupid. But those
people must never have met your guide or
Kurt - the punk rock nerdfighter. Kurt and
the guide were ready for experiences.
Things may be a little bit out of the
ordinary, maybe even a little bit illegal.
Illegal experiences I do not condone.
When the opportunity presents itself why
ignore something new, something
interesting, something different. But I'm
proud of you for fighting your fear and
going ahead and chasing after that
experience. I'm starting to very
seriously consider the prospect that as
you get older, you get stupider
incrementally, every year, stupider, and
stupider. What I mean is that maybe you
have a bad experience or you put your
values in all the wrong places and you
end up really consciously avoiding
anything that might be fun. I mean go to
any Walmart in America and watch what
happens. The little kids put things on
their heads, run around, act silly, do
stupid things and then their parents are
like: "Billy, you can't do that in Walmart,
this is just not the place for having
fun". You know what? I think we should all
be at Walmart putting stuff on our heads.
We need to take a cue from the
four-year-olds of the world.
Putting things on your head is fun. Fun is good
for you. There's no Walmart police force
telling you not to put things on your
head. More than a dozen people completely
ignored me when I was sitting on the
street giving away peeps. What I felt
like I was saying was here, this is
something different, something that
doesn't generally happen to you in your
normal day.
Take this strangeness, this experience
and have some fun with it. Kurt heard me
loud and clear but that's not what most
of the people heard. They heard something
like: "I'm weird and weird people are
dangerous". If you find yourself getting
older and less silly, do something about it.
Put something on your head, do it, put
it on your head. I'll see you tomorrow.